is it such an amazing thing for
especially I was a young girl that
played soccer like that's a that's a
really cool thing to like watch a woman
that you idolize like make it and not
just make it like bad kind of make it
you know I think I think that to answer
your question it's it's it seems
difficult like why would somebody be
upset about that but I think the the
commentary was they'd never seen
something like that before
and so that that makes people
uncomfortable right and so 99 let's say
98 percent was like oh my gosh this was
the greatest sporting event I ever went
to I'm so happy that I got to bring my
kids there's always going to be someone
in your life or some organization that
doesn't believe in what you believe in
or see the things the same way you see
them that's an opportunity to bring
people together so for me it was like
let's have a conversation
you know I did the interviews you know
you know now my granddaughter wants to
take off her top and you know and you
were you sexualizing sports and I mean
Aaron lookit she's heard this story
already but this is what I said come out
see what we do give it a try
you'll understand listen in 99 we were
responsible for the future of women's
soccer it would have all gone away oh
that was cute you ignited the domino
effect
yeah and instead you know that team took
on all that responsibility and
understood how to filter that and to do
what they do how to do at the right time
and be ready to be champions you know
that that is not easy to do but they did
it at the right time and so hard work in
my opinion hard work should be a common
denominator we all should work hard
that's you know you got we all don't and
that's why only some of them have a
champion yeah I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this